today we're talking about tao vm's
bigquery security the future of
computing
and gaming i'm stephanie wong and
welcome to this week in cloud where we
serve you
the lowest latency news scale out
workloads demand the best
combo of performance and price to bring
down the cost of delivering applications
all while providing an excellent user
experience we are excited to announce a
new vm family
tau vms coming to google cloud tau vms
extend compute engine's vm offerings
with a new option
optimized for cost-effective performance
of scale out workloads
we're excited to announce the ga of
bigquery row level security
which gives customers a way to control
access to subsets of data
in the same table for different groups
of users
row level security rls extends the
principle of least privileged access and
enables fine grained access control
policies
in bigquery tables bigquery currently
supports access controls at the project
data set table and column level
since quantum computing is the next
technological revolution and we want to
make it
universally accessible we're excited to
announce that quantum computers
from ion q are now available on the
google cloud marketplace
developers researchers and enterprises
alike can now
access ion-q's high-fidelity 11 qubit
system
via google cloud in just a few clicks
with billing and provisioning
handled via their existing google
accounts
with the surge of new gamers and an
increase in time spent
playing games in the last year is more
important than ever to delight
and engage players we're here to help
you build high quality experiences and
take your games
to the next level join us for our online
event on july 12th
to the 13th to catch deep dives full of
best practices
to help you continue creating great
games connecting with players
and scaling your business if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud